CHAMPION THE VALUES WITHOUT
APOLOGY.
>> Jeanine: JOINING US NOW
WITH REACTION, DEPUTY ASSISTANT
TO THE PRESIDENT FOR STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS ON THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL MICHAEL ANTIN.
GOOD EVENING, MICHAEL.
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH WAS VERY
CONSISTENT WITH EVERYTHING HE'S
BEEN SAYING SINCE THE CAMPAIGN,
ABOUT IMPROVED ECONOMIC
SITUATION IN THIS COUNTRY WITH
THE STOCK MARKET AS WELL AS THE
DEFEAT OF ISIS.
IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH IT'S A ONE
YEAR REPORT CARD WHERE HE
SUCCEEDED.
IT'S ALSO A SPEECH TO ROLL OUT,
INTRODUCED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THE STRATEGY DOCUMENT.
THAT STRATEGY DOCUMENT IS
INFORMED FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE
AND OF COURSE ALL OF HIS ACTIONS
IN 2017 TO CHANGE THE COURSE OF
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY.
HE WANTED TO BOTH TALK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT STRATEGY
OR AT LEAST THE NEW STRATEGY
DOCUMENT.
AS I SAY IT'S A STRATEGY THAT
HAS ARTIE BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
THIS YEAR.
AND TO A REPORT CARD TO SAY TO
THEM THIS IS WHAT I'VE BEEN
DOING.
TAKING GOING FORWARD.
>> Jeanine: AND WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT DEFEATING
ISIS AND RECAPTURING ALMOST 100%
OF THE TERRITORY THAT THEY HAD
CONQUERED.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT HE WOULD BE
GETTING SOME CREDIT FOR THAT,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS LIKE, YOU
IT'S GOING TO TAKE YEARS.
THIS PRESIDENT COMES IN, IT'S
LIKE THEY ARE GONE.
>> HE'S GETTING SOME CREDIT FOR
IT, BUT I AGREE WITH YOU NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH.
A LOT OF THE REASON WHY THAT
CAMPAIGN ACCELERATED SO QUICKLY
THIS YEAR WAS A FUNDAMENTAL
MICROMANAGING DECISIONS BEING
OPPOSED TO DEVOLVED DOWN TO
COMMANDERS IN THE FIELD TO MAKE
THE DECISIONS THAT THEY BEST
SOFFIT.
SO WE SEEN A REALLY RAPID
DEGRADATION OF ISIS CAPABILITIES
THE PHYSICAL CALIPHATE.
HE SAID NEARLY 100%.
THE WAY THERE YET, BUT CERTAINLY
WE ARE MILES AHEAD OF WHERE WE
WORK WHEN THIS ADMINISTRATION
CAME INTO OFFICE.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHEN THEY DON'T CONTROL
TERRITORY, POPULATION CENTERS
AND RESOURCES, THEIR ABILITY TO
PROJECT POWER AND THREATEN US AT